the men and women of raqqa's being
slaughtered silently
are real journalistic heroes
[Music]
they work in secret and under constant
threat
reporting on the depredations of isis
in their home city some have fled in
fear for their own lives
even in exile they are in no way
safe the website raqqa is being
slaughtered silently
publishes first-hand accounts of the war
crimes of isis in often horrific detail
city of ghosts a new documentary by
academy award-nominated documentarian
matthew heinemann
tells the story of the citizen
journalists who risk their lives
to show the world the atrocities
committed by the islamic state of iraq
and syria
you know after isis took over the the
city you know there really was not any
information going
or information going on there were no
western journalists
there they would be killed instantly
and so you know this group
um really provided a service to the
world to help understand the atrocities
that were being committed
uh in their hometown which just happened
to be you know the capital of the
islamic state
basically we're working in two groups so
the first
group is operating raqqa and there are
17 colleagues
and we are almost 10 outside so the
first
group our team in raqqa they
like they take photos videos they send
us the news information
and they send it like to the second team
outside and the second team publish it
online on social
media on our website and in the same
time we
smuggle information and because raqqa
is cut off from the entire orders like
no satellites no tv
mostly there are no internet so we
spread a magazine inside raqqa city so
our magazine has the same cover of isis
magazine to reach out
the largest number of audience so
it's a main tool to educate the people
about the
geology of isis about the risk of isis
you know i think one of the remarkable
things about the group
is that these guys didn't have to do
this you know they didn't have to become
citizen journalists they
they're all studying to be doctors and
lawyers and scientists and
but they chose to do this this choice
came with enormous consequences
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i don't want to shy away from the
violence i don't want to shy away from
the reality
the horror the fear uh that the citizens
of raqqa live with every single day
on the other hand i didn't want people
in theaters to sort of you know run out
because it was
so extreme and so you know very much
try to walk that tightrope
but again i i don't think it would do
justice to the story
um to the group to all that they've been
through to to shy away from this
violence and i think it's
you know it's important to show um to
help people empathize
for what they live with every single day
for sure like uh
to watch uh your colleagues or like uh
your family members your relatives are
getting killed
it's like something not easy and like
especially
i was like with my colleague who watched
the video the execution video of his
father
so i don't know
i don't know how he's feeling now and he
keep watching this video
but like when i asked him he said that
this like watching this video
gave him like more power to complete the
war
so it was like a hard thing but like
watching these videos or like the video
of our colleagues our
family members it gives it give us
like more power to complete our work
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
i can't compare our group with isis i
says
like the media officer like in derisor
as an example
is getting like a hundred thousand fifty
five
dollars monthly to do their work and
we're running out of fun
so they have all the equipments to shut
their videos and we're working with like
simple equipment
so first we can compare both sides and
then
but even without all these fun
even experience we were able to make a
change
so and that's the reason why isis
started to target us specifically you
know in this world of sort of
fake news and where truth seems to be
malleable
i i think there's not there's no more
important story to tell than the story
of people
fighting for the truth people seeking
the truth people
mixed in their lives uh to expose the
truth
and you know that's one of the one of
the biggest motivations for me to make
this film
uh was to highlight the incredible work
that aziz and his colleagues are doing
to some degree this film is an homage to
journalism or homage to citizen
journalism
homage to fighting for the truth
either we will win or they will kill all
of us
you